[Music]
all right what if I told you that
Vietnam now has according to them the
world's first 24 karat gold-plated hotel
exterior and interior damn it looks like
the Willy Wonka elevator
but how would big steel yeah I would
imagine like people in the shoe so it's
just like yeah old because it's exterior
and this is so Dubai but it's in Vietnam
was very dividing up my dad there and
watch the inside is trash dude no I mean
all the furniture oh yeah that gold real
gold or is it just a 24 karat yeah name
of the color it's like Champa hot [ __ ]
what if they got a paint that's called
24 karat gold am so how much is it to
say that I know oh do you really want to
know prevent the construction workers
from not stealing the bricks
they're saying it's a six star hotel
what if I a six star hotels really do
they have a seven one or no it's just
say maybe it's only gold well if an all
gold hotel is only six and I don't want
to know what a seven star is that 700
some diamonds after oh yeah yeah yeah
what if they have like a clear coating
over it speak up dude
I'm talking to Tim needs it for having a
conversation why are you butting in well
yeah so this is in Hanoi and you guys
have heard right like yeah oh I have
heard from Joe that Vietnam is extremely
affordable like everything's really
really really and on the up and up like
crazy exponentially yeah exactly so I
thought you're laughing at me I don't
like insider inside dope
okay anyway so they are saying that to
stay there it will be at least 250
dollars per night
that's cheapest [ __ ] [ __ ] Vietnam or a
gold as hotel this comfort ends more
[ __ ] expensive in America bro bro
there's also uh so this is a hotel slash
apartment building but people aren't
able to buy the like to actually own the
apartment they're only they can only
rent and so they're saying that it's a
25 floor building and they will be
selling these apartments at about six
thousand five hundred dollars per square
meter how do you a [ __ ] up if it's 24
karat should be 24 we so they're selling
them or not 24 everything know so to
rent to rent
yeah so it'd be like six thousand five
hundred dollars per square meter to
Brent that's it
crazy amount of money yes all my cuz it
just month I don't know it just that's
all the info I got should be our next
writers retreat Vietnam Hanoi Golden
Lake Hotel and it's open I'm actually um
Twitter 50 and night this is crazy
that's insane I know or we can you just
go to Vegas a lesser flight for free
don't you get tired of the same thing no
I'm sorry there's so much to do in Vegas
there's a ton to do yeah let's like say
you need to say that by everything you
get tired of your wife your husband
[Laughter]
loving character you know oh yeah charm
bin the Vietnam no I think he has she
told me he was haunted haunted was I
mean no thanks
haunted as well maybe where she was
staying does the word yeah yeah but
because the war all the locals are like
yo this place is [ __ ] haunted to they
everyone knows like the whole country I
believe it yes I will pass you guys been
I've been to Germany is [ __ ] crazy
that's my feeling I'm talking about
Nikki it felt heavy as [ __ ] just being
there just walking around there
it does feel it does feel kind of eerie
in handy just like the whole country
itself I was in Berlin I don't know
about the rest of country I was in
Berlin and it was [ __ ] heavy bro
schnitzel and you like feeling heavy you
ever walk through a place where you've
looked at a history book and you're like
yeah but that's Berlin right so you're
looking at the world war ii [ __ ] you're
like oh my god this is literally the
place where the nazis walked and [ __ ]
okay the nazis were [ __ ] monster
nancy's do you believe in spirits Tim
yeah how did you [ __ ] it have you
encountered any no not like a directs
nothing would be like oh I just had a
thing with a spirit I do remember and
this is like a faint memory because I
was so young in Thailand
my parents we're in a van with their
friends we were driving somewhere it was
late at night okay and apparently this
area was kind of haunted and then all of
a sudden I think my dad's friend's wife
who was driving like freaked out and
like pulled over and she was like
shaking and she was like I saw a group
of people in the middle of the street
and when they pulled over there was
nobody there but she was like sure oh my
god one of the scariest YouTube videos I
remember watching this is like back in I
remember I had just gotten pregnant so
like 2007 and so YouTube was new back
then - anyway so I remember watching
this really [ __ ] scary video of these
group of people there inside of a car
and it's nighttime there on this lonely
road and then up ahead they see this
woman and so they pull over and they're
like hey do you need help or whatever
this woman just look weird like a
[ __ ] ghost
and then so she ain't they end up
getting her in the car and then they
were like like where do you need to go
like do you want us to take you to a
hospital or whatever and then the girl
ends up saying something like oh yeah my
car's just up ahead and so they end up
driving and then she ends up saying like
right before they they hit this
particular area
saying like this is where I died and
then like the whole frickin video gets
all like oh sure yeah the video gets all
like like static and [ __ ] they have that
in a like in the Bay Area there's like a
road that we don't go down because of
that well just they got our CDs for
someone was like oh cool a video about a
goal don't open up like so I know if
it's like similar to that where it
basically with the saying this is like
with multiple people hear from other
people like everyone knows I think is a
Mission Road it's like in the hill or
something but it's a there's like always
a girl walking down the road and like do
like don't stop don't pick her up always
we're going like a wedding dress right
and this is the same thing like I just
leave my cars down there and they're
talking about how like she's dead well
yeah this girl in this video was wearing
a white dress I think oh yeah it could
be that no but they weren't speaking
English oh really this is just like some
story that everyone tells them maybe
create up I get [ __ ] with all the time
as I sleep and it's profit yes you see
paralysis thank you and I've talked
about it a bunch and I'm I'm happy to
talk about it cuz I'm sick of all the
[ __ ] like it sucks I've dealt with
in my whole life and yeah every couple
nights including three nights ago 309
well okay it always starts off with this
thing right so I do this thing sometimes
where I can make myself feel really good
energetically wise will by just like I
almost like meditating and a place
tiffen us when you realize your urine
your traffic no no as me right now I can
coming into JK news I was doing a thing
where or any time I'm about to be on
camera I do a thing we're it's like a
ritual for me where I come in with a lot
of energy and so I feel like people who
are around me they feel my energy when I
come in the room but the other night
sometimes I do it while I'm sleeping and
one and that's what it's scary because I
do it so much during my regular life
like almost like my meditation process
that when I'm sleeping I do it too and
when I'm sleeping that's when it's
scariest [ __ ] because I think that
there's bad things around us sometimes
and they know when I'm doing this what
I'm sleeping and I'm not even doing it
purposely I think that
wait during this and unfortunately
there's some crossover and so then these
[ __ ] are like hanging over my bed and
they're trying to get inside my body
while I'm like do under that's how I
feel especially like when I'm having
sleep paralysis like I don't like to
feel like I get the feeling every single
time without a doubt like them just
crawling up on me exactly and then like
and then like I get chills my jewels
shells exploding eighty times and then
it rushes to your head right and then
all of a sudden you hear that like a
sound just gets louder and golden and
then sometimes they say let me in that
happens to be - you wouldn't get this
regularly for me I [ __ ] hate you
still get that yeah this happened we
both have stupid dreams that we're not
even talking to each other about it ya
know the whispering what happened to me
when I was wide awake trying to vote
asleep I thought wasn't asleep yet but I
used to always hear whispers of like
behind and it's like you like your back
like cuz sometimes you just like say
it's quiet easy your thoughts get loud
but you're like that wasn't I thought no
they're literally saying my name so your
ears I can see process not the the
feeling all I get is like I'm awake I
know I'm awake I cannot move right and I
literally have to like throw my body and
like do everything I try trying them
like break out of that big one and did I
get out of it Wow yeah but you know what
sucks though is that like I know that
that's the key right to move and then
break out of it but like I'm in it so
often that my mind tricks me and be like
you are moving you are moving right and
it's like why aren't you we don't have
my body connection can you see yourself
and you're not moving your eyes are just
like slightly open and you're just like
move damn it [ __ ] move by the way
sometimes it's [ __ ] cuz sometimes I
have a dream that I'm having sleep
paralysis and that's a [ __ ] yeah and
then sometimes I'm having sleep
paralysis is real there's a [ __ ]
differentiation between the two I hate
those dreams where you're dreaming and
you wake up in your dreams
in a [ __ ] nightmare to go cuz I fall
asleep in my computer share all the time
and I I was sitting up and I'm listening
to some [ __ ] and then I remember a loud
bang the loudest bang you ever heard in
your [ __ ] life over my head and then
I'm like oh [ __ ] this is really bad and
then all the chills come over my whole
body like the spider chills yes man I
woke up but I didn't wake up and it was
a dream about me having a dream about
sleeper oh my god that was [ __ ] oh it
was a sea problem it's like Inception
like how do you even know there is a
difference you can feel it cuz when you
wake up you're like oh my god I was just
over my body I mean the exact same spot
like this time I wasn't in my computer I
was in my bed already so I knew it was
different do you ever get the sleep
paralysis where you just can't move at
all and then Austin like your dick just
starts getting really hard it starts
growing and growing you can't even move
or anything
dick is growing because you could feel
it and it's like pressing against the
sheet and you feel the the president
sucking on your yeah I feel William
Howard Taft sucking my dick off I've
heard from a couple people that when
they get sleep paralysis and they feel a
presence on them to to cuss and that'll
make it go away for real yeah okay so so
I had make him a tune on the podcast one
podcast one time she and she was saying
she felt a presence and like like
pressing her down I'm not gonna she was
like what the [ __ ] and then went away
and then so Nicki blades chimes in and
she's like oh in Hawaii they call that
depressing ghosts and it's like a
presence that will like will be in your
bedroom or whatever and it'll put
pressure on you but the way to make him
go away is to like cuss at him oh and
that's like a thing in Mexico they call
it like when the ghost jumps on top of
your body yeah and like every culture
this day possible my friend from high
school
her mom felt like somebody was like
grabbing her arm while she was sleeping
and I see huh cold was it cold no no it
was just like someone was just grabbing
her like really really hard right and
like it was hurting and then she also
felt like somebody like just pressing on
her like sitting on her right and so
like she felt like it was really hard to
breathe and so when she woke up she saw
her husband
like hey did you did you grab my arm
were you trying to like wake me up and
he was like no and then she looked at
her arm and like you know like she
wasn't even holding on to it but she saw
marks on her arms and all the so that's
not me my sister felt the same thing and
then she said it was a cold feeling when
she felt it the whole movie The Exorcism
of Emily Rose like that was like based
on a true story yeah they say it's the
scientific thing is talking about
there's a that your body your mind wakes
up but your body hasn't so so your
body's still in that state of being
asleep we're shuts down your body is
there's no mind-body connection anymore
it's severed so then that's what your
body's what do I seem stronger then oh
water's just genetic